AT THE TIME, JOE BIDEN DIDN’T
NEED A RUNNING MATE AND CNN
WASN’T WATCHING.
WE ARE JOINED NOW BY
JUDGE ANDREW NAPOLITANO.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
SO YOU’VE SPENT THE LAST -- THE
20 YEARS I’VE KNOWN YOU --
TALKING ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND HOW CENTRAL THEY ARE TO THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE, ENSHRINED
IN OUR DOCUMENTS.
I HAVEN’T HEARD ANY TALK ABOUT
THEM RECENTLY.
ARE THEY STILL RELEVANT?
>> ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES SAID IN
A CARTOON OF THE FRAMERS SIGNING
THE CONSTITUTION AND IN THIS
CARTOON, WASHINGTON TURNS TO
MADISON AND SAYS LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT, NONE OF THIS COUNTS OF
PEOPLE GET SICK, RIGHT?
SORT OF A HUMOROUS WAY OF
MOCKING WHAT’S HAPPENING TODAY.
YOUR ANALYSIS OF
GOVERNOR WHITMER COULD APPLY TO
NEARLY ALL THE REMAINING 49
GOVERNORS WHO ASSUME THAT THEY
HAVE THE POWER TO CRUSH
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTIES, VIOLATE
THE CONSTITUTION, AND WRITE
LAWS.
THEY DON’T.
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE WRITTEN
BY LEGISLATIVE BRANCHES, AND
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND DEBATES.
THERE’S A TRANSPARENCY SO WE
KNOW WHY SHE DOESN’T WANT YOU TO
BUY GARDEN HOSES.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE A RATIONAL
BASIS TO ARTICULATE FOR IT BUT
WHEN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TAKES
IT UPON ITSELF, THE ROLE OF NOT
JUST ENFORCING THE LAW BUT OF
MAKING UP NEW ONES AND IN THE
PROCESS CRASHES BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL LIBERTIES LIKE THE
RIGHT TO TRAVEL AND THE RIGHT TO
WORSHIP, NEVER MIND ON
EASTER SUNDAY BUT ON ANY TIME
YOU WANT TO WORSHIP, WE ARE
WITNESSING THE SLOW DEATH, THE
DEATH IN SLOW MOTION OF
LIBERTIES BECAUSE THESE
GOVERNORS, THESE PETTY TYRANTS
WILL USE THIS POWER AGAIN AND
AGAIN UNTIL SOME COURAGEOUS
FEDERAL COURT OR AN OUTRAGED
PUBLIC STOPS THEM.
>> Tucker: I’M SO THANKFUL
THAT YOU POINTED OUT IT’S NOT
JUST GOVERNOR WHITMER.
IS GOVERNOR HOGAN IN MARYLAND,
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THEM.
VERY QUICKLY, DO YOU THINK THERE
IS A MECHANISM FOR PULLING THEM
BACK A LITTLE BIT NOW?
>> HOPEFULLY IT WILL BE OUTRAGE
STIRRED UP BY THE TYPE OF
REPORTING THAT YOU AND SOME OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE BEGUN TO BE
DOING IT EVEN SOME OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE LEFT HAVE BEEN
DOING SOME OF THIS REPORTING
PERIOD OF BUT BASIC HUMAN
LIBERTIES ARE GUARANTEED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
THEY CAN’T EVEN BE TAKEN AWAY BY
THE VOTE OF THE LEGISLATURE,
MUCH LESS THE COMMAND OF A
GOVERNOR OR A MAYOR.
THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS LOOK LIKE
ORDERS THAT SOUND LIKE ORDERS.
THEY ARE JUST GUIDELINES.
THEY DON’T HAVE THAT, THERE
CANNOT BE A CRIMINAL SANCTION
BECAUSE THEY ARE AT THEIR ROOT
JUST THE WHIM OF THOSE IN POWER
INTENDED TO ENHANCE THEIR POWER,
BUT THEY ARE NOT VALID
EXPRESSIONS OF CONSTITUTIONAL
DOCUMENTS.